we think these sanctions are biting John
Bolton was the third National Security
Advisor pointed by President Trump since
taking office and he's the third to
resign after much speculation of
imminent firing Bolton brought to the
White House decades of experience in
foreign policy and a hawkish disposition
that had never wavered he served as
ambassador to the United Nations and the
George W Bush from 2005 to 2006 and used
that position to continue to justify the
US invasion of Iraq that he had
relentlessly advocated a few years
before Madam President
he returned to the UN alongside
President Trump as national security
adviser during the General Assembly
session last year and once again made
his presence felt we've imposed very
stringent sanctions on Iran more are
coming and what we expect from Iran is
massive changes in their behavior yes
sir national security control of the US
mission at the UN effectively
downgrading the role played by
ambassador nikki Haley who resigned
within months of his appointment what
many diplomats say is that it's very
hard to get clear decisions out of the
US mission to the UN at present and that
is probably because Bolton and other
members of the administration are
fighting over what policy lines to take
the administration appeared united in
its America first policy some
differences began to emerge particularly
with regard to North Korea
chairman Kim asked for this meeting
President Trump agreed where Bolton
adopted a take-it-or-leave-it attitude
in negotiations leading to North Korea
and complaints that he was undermining
the policy of dialogue advocated by both
President Trump and Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo the Iranian regime has
systematically pursued a policy of
hostility toward the United States then
the apparent moment of real division as
he'd done in years past a National
Security Adviser began to press for
active regime change in Iran
characterizing the scheduled deployment
of the u.s. feet to the region as in his
words a clear and unmistakable message
to the Iranian regime
thus at odds with a White House policy
in which the focus was more on exerting
economic pressure through sanctions
after weeks of discussion it was
confirmed that additional troops would
be sent to the region but numbering
hundreds rather than the tens of
thousands at Bolton was believed to be
pressing for president Trump denied
there was friction within his cabinet
I think it's fake news okay now would I
do that absolutely but we have not
planned for that hopefully we're not
gonna have to plan for that and if we
did that would send a hell of a lot more
troops than that the final straw perhaps
a sardonic comment by a principal
adviser to the Iranian president who
wrote in a tweet at real Donald Trump
you wanted a better deal with Iran looks
like you're going to get a war instead
that's what happens when you listen to
the moustache good luck in 2020 John
Bolton is now on his way out his
moustache intact his dream of regime
change shattered my kanna al Jazeera
Washington